[Music]
this 160 yard strip of land separating
east and west berlin was militarized for
decades
[Music]
now it's a space for
karaoke
this great big story was made possible
by the german national tourist board and
hanse merkor travel insurance
[Music]
what was once the most dangerous border
in the world is now home to an
amphitheater where you can find hundreds
of karaoke fans from all over gathering
every sunday thanks to this guy
my name is joe hachiban i'm the founder
the creator the instigator of bear pit
karaoke
therapy karaoke is an open-air karaoke
show
i started breakfast karaoke in the
late winter early spring of 2009.
everybody
takes place in an amphitheater in a park
called maura park in the prince harbor
district of berlin
around three o'clock on sunday
afternoons when the weather's good i
show up with a bike load of uh
equipment and set it up and a couple of
minutes later usually we're we're
looking at our first singer
[Applause]
[Music]
singers come from far and wide to flaunt
their pipes at the bear pit the mao park
event brings people together from all
over the world you actually hear less
german singing than people from the
netherlands people from africa people
from latin america people from north
america scottish people irish people so
it's just a very great place
i love the feeling when you just go
there be on the stage sing in front of
all these people and they
start singing with you and i don't know
out of this world
despite the area's harrowing past or
maybe because of it malware park
demonstrates germans and berliners
willingness to confront history and work
together to move on
everybody sort of
describes it as a sort of thing that
sort of fits the idea of berlin
the special moments
that have happened over the years for me
they're when everybody's just for a
little bit more than a split second on
the same page you know that we all get
goose pimples at the same time and all
know that something just is or was
pretty special
[Music]